wenn dirk brauer seine touren fährt
macht ihm das richtig spaß denn das neue
fahrrad nimmt ihm arbeit ab
kaum dass der kurierfahrer in die
pedalen tritt verstärkt ein elektromotor
automatisch die beinarbeit
so kann der kurierfahrer nicht nur zügig
fahren sondern auch mühelos schwerer
fach zum kunden bringen
sein rat ist ein elektro last rate man
kann ganz ganz entspannt in den tag
fahren man wenn man las hat dieses
elektro polizei die last so weg man
merkt die 50 kilo überhaupt nicht seit
der kurierdienst die last räder hat
gehen auch kurze touren in der berliner
innenstadt schnell weg denn was für die
auto- kuriere eine zumutung ist ist für
die schnellen radler kein problem
auf radwegen und durch parks schlängeln
sie sich an allen staus vorbei der
kurierdienst will die last rat flotte
deshalb zügig ausbauen
frank müller hat sich das elektrische
last rat ausgedacht seit 2012
produzieren er und seine acht
mitarbeiter die räder in serie
rund 5000 euro kostet 1 neben
kurierdiensten postboten und kleinen
geschäften hat franck muller handwerker
in großstädten als mögliche kunden im
blick
die wenig sachen mitnehmen müssen und
die eben überschaubare palette von
werkzeug haben schnell in den ort kommen
wollen und immer wieder kurzfristig
weiterfahren wollen 100 kilometer am tag
sind maximal drin
dann muss die batterie die unter der
transportkiste steckt für ein paar
stunden an die steckdose stromkosten für
die 100 kilometer 12 cent
höchstgeschwindigkeit 25
stundenkilometer einigen kunden war das
zu langsam
deshalb haben sich die entwickler hier
ins zeug gelegt und dem drahtesel noch
einmal richtig dampf gemacht
heraus kam dieses sogenannte s pedelec
das darf zwar in deutschland nicht mehr
auf den radweg bringt es dafür aber oft
45 stundenkilometer gerade bei rush hour
sind diese cargo e bikes oder lasten
fahrräder deutlich schneller als
normales auto und ganz entscheidend man
hat immer ein parkplatz man hat keine
parkplatzprobleme und 100 räder verkauft
die firma im jahr tausende sollen es
bald werden
dabei hat frank müller auch die
riesenstädte asiens als absatzmarkt im
blick die ersten elektrischen lastesel
made in berlin hat irgendwie bereits
nach singapur verkauft